but if you want to be with this person
at this point in your life there are
certain things that come with it yeah
there's certain things that you have to
be with there's certain rules that you
have to regulate you have to keep in
line
not because i want to control you but
because i have experienced from past and
know that bro that only leads to this
bro i don't want to have to be going to
you two weeks from now bro like what's
this bread doing putting hot faces and
things like this that's another argument
for us bro that didn't need to be there
bro because at the end of the day you
don't know you're not going to answer
him you don't even you don't even know
who he is but he's pissing me off bro
because he but i wouldn't do that if i
was your man oh but i'll take you here
look pictures hitting you know what
other men are like bro because you would
do that yourself but no not you but
you do that
like that there's like bro like he's not
doing it how i'm doing it kind of thing
like and i mean it's a banner that men
do but some girls do fall for that or
girls fall for that at a certain time
from us the right man
like that that true the way that drake
trolled that guy's wife 100 100 million
percent bro like if it's drake holler if
i was holding her she back that's the
dms if it's a certain guy that she's
interested in now it becomes a problem
because now she's sitting down being
like
i like him
you ain't doing what he's doing
if i wanted to i could leave you and go
to him so you better fix up and it's
like wait hold on hold on a minute i
work 40 hours a week i provide for you i
might not be like rich and taking no no
no no but i'm doing so so so and so and
so bro as certain men certain men do
certain things that other men can't live
up to bro
i i have a question for you want a
polyamorous relationship and
a few wives yes
so is it will it be okay for your wives
to also absolutely not trust
that
that's not
do you want men do you multiple men
do i want more yeah if you're with me
and i'm looking after you do you want
multiple men i wouldn't be with a man in
a polyamorous relationship exactly
because you don't want multiple men i'm
saying to you i want multiple women
because that's the thing that's the
point of meeting someone's needs and
knowing that you you're not going for
that so like you wouldn't want to be in
that so you're not going for that but
you would be fine with it it's not the
same because there's things that my
woman could do that i can't do that i'll
just give it back to you just be just
waiting for the difference many men
many men it's it's acceptable for them
to be polygamous but not for the woman
and that's just something like you don't
have to understand it
but it's just how it is so it's not
shocking that he's saying
yes like i'm i'm going to be pulling a
miss and and the wife is like agreeing
to be in that polygamous relationship
it's not going to work i just believe
that women i just believe i mean
i mean okay i'm the man you're the woman
we're in a polygamous relationship
you've got a next man i've got to wait
until your man's come what on tuesday
until like what so what he did he does
the tuesday thing and i do the wednesday
thing are you ready for the wednesday
thing after you've had the choose dating
and then
when you're pregnant
i believe women can't love two people at
the same time
they can't bro
speak into the mic speaking
like women can't love two guys at the
same time you can't love this guy you
love him like he provides for you
protects you brother and then at the
same time you love this guy as well
because i can't you can't you're like i
think of course but but i'm saying men
can love to like multiple women at like
probably different i think that it's
women they can they can love
multiple men but it's different types of
love and you're not going to have the
same love you have for this guy over
here that you have for this guy he could
be doing stuff for you that this guy's
not doing and this guy could be doing
stuff for you that this guy over here
isn't doing so you love them for
different reasons i think that they can
i personally don't think that women can
be in multiple relationships because
that is emotionally draining for women
to have to be emotionally connected this
person mostly connect to that person in
over a friendship obviously people can
do it in friendship but when it comes
romantically
i think we're built for just one person
and that's why well not all women
because
there's some women who
can do it do you have male friends
i do have male friends do you have any
male friends that you're sexually
attracted to
huh
do you have any male friends that you
are sexually as you said it's a female
friend
have you got any male friends that
you're sexually attracted to not
sexually exactly bro that's my point bro
girls put men that they're not attracted
to in the friend zone bro them don't do
no you can be you can be attracted to
them but not sexually attracted
i understand that there's a difference
between okay like she's nice like but i
won't sleep no i'm talking about you're
sexually attracted to you it's not
really necessary for a woman to have a
man that she's sexually attracted to in
the friend zone otherwise he wouldn't
necessarily yeah but he's depressed but
he would be sexually attracted to her
though 100
you have a relationship with a girl and
she's got bear friends that are sexually
attracted to her no that's why i said
the last show was can men and women be
we'll talk about can men and women be
friends you know what i'm saying and i'm
like
women don't have
generally okay i'm sure there are
exceptions to the rule but women don't
have
male friends and i said if you think you
got a male friend
call him up at midnight yeah tell him to
come over and have a little drink and
then put it on him and see what he does
yeah because nine times out of ten he's
gonna be like oh okay all right cool and
but if he says
no
that's your friend but can i ask you
something here why is it okay for men to
sleep with women that they're not
necessarily
feeling sexually attractively but women
they have that kind of thing where
listen i have the barrier of
i'm not really like i could give it i
can give it to you and it'll probably be
good but i'm not going to do it because
like the coochie's what you want because
a woman knows that because it's not just
about it's not just about knowing what
we have it's there's an emotional
connection that comes with when we have
sex with somebody it's not just like oh
i'm gonna get my rock my socks off
whatever get it boom bam boom it's
something that we release physically
that is just innate in us the i forgot
what the uh but some women can do that
now woman some women are some women with
it that's great
guys one time one time i think that
that's a lie like um that women
like i i do know that women are just
having sex with everyone but i think
they're just lying to themselves like
that they're not attracted or like have
any kind of bond with whoever they're
having sex with i think that's damn well
a lot
no i know people personally who are like
i just needed a itch to be scratched and
they just do that and i feel like that's
a lie like i know some people that are
like
so as a woman if you have that sexual
urge there's no there's no one that you
can go to but i just want that itch to
be scratched
you have to have an emotional bond with
them
if i'm having sex with someone i have
some sort of bond with them like i no
that's not what you're asking he's
asking if you i'm saying if you're if
you're if you're in your house and
you're thinking oh i feel kind of you
know
i get what you're saying but i'm saying
i wouldn't just have sex with someone
because it's like oh like i would have
to have some sort of like
attraction for them for me you'd have to
be a friend or something but i'm saying
an emotional bond like can you can you
as a woman like have sex with a man and
have no emotional bond with him i don't
think that's possible that's what i'm
saying right so if you know that then
why why when i cheat is the same as you
cheating i didn't say i cheated no no no
in general
if you know that you're not if you know
that it's impossible for you to be to be
emotionally disconnected from someone
and you know men is capable of doing it
why do you think that it should be the
same for men and women if you know that
we're going to be different how we react
to it
i i think the the point is about honesty
and say how you're saying about trump
not i i understand you darling i get the
honesty part i get the trust being
broken i'm saying the principle of it
because like i said there's people that
will go for whatever you're on so you
don't have to you don't have to like put
up this facade like you can just be real
and say xyz do you know what yeah when
you tell the truth you get what you want
yeah that's what it does it actually
might take longer it might take longer
because
that's what i've come to realize like
and that's something that i've learned
in my age like
it might take longer for you to get what
you want but the more you tell the truth
about yourself the more you the people
start gravitating towards you and you
will be surprised as to how many women
like you said are actually down for a
polygamous relationship
i bet you if you start telling women up
front
i want to be polyamorous you'll find the
women that you want and they'll come
back
i do and i do have a lot of women that i
do and i'm saying i could be devil's
advocate and say i lie and i'm
explaining to you why men lie i'm
perfectly because you know honestly i
don't think i'm the best man in the
world bro but i think if she's average
bro i'm getting there bro
that's it and if i don't get her it's
her loss bro and it's like brav um
you might you might think i'm bit like i
have to have this kind of attitude if i
know otherwise i ain't gonna get it like
i have to have it
if i don't if i ain't got this attitude
i'm not gonna get her so i've got this
attitude and she likes it and
she's feeding off it and it's like
i like this i'm not coming on this oh i
need to take the couch no listen y'all
i'm letting you know it is boom boom
boom you know my bad gal i'm saying man
from caribbean and that and i'm trying
to say you know how to swing it you know
you're noticing it do you know what's
going on
i'm not gonna do it in your face because
the attitude that you have here a lot of
women will be like this guy i can't take
this guy but there's a lot of they love
it i love it
my instagram says last time
like yo you sure you like that like you
couldn't you know
bro i'm not into no [ __ ]
relationships this is what this is where
the problem comes in because they'll
know they'll love that kind of guy and
then they'll want to change him for
themselves but then when they ch if that
kind of the thing is when you're a man
if you're a man if you're a man and you
change and you fold into that bro
she starts despising you sam but i don't
want it to change i'm just saying if you
want me to change you've got to do some
changes
all right all right all right no no you
if you delete your instagram i'm not
going to chat to bear gap i'm not gonna
chirps bro because i'm in a relationship
with you i'm going to be 100
for you bro i'm i'm going to stop
chirping but wait wait wait that's a lot
for two other people dad
that's a lot bro
because you just said you're going to be
100 for her but you know that you want a
polyamorous relationship so how can you
be a hundred percent cause i could be a
hundred percent twice three hundred
percent of course i can
and it's club
it's 100 it's a rule yeah that you get
hundred percent islam you can have
multiple wives i'm not gonna hit united
time so at this time it's a rule in it
like you have to treat your wives
equally you understand that that's what
i'm saying that's why i me saying in the
real world that's not practical though
it's not practical it doesn't work but i
mean if you know the premise
because you know like when you have a
parent yeah everyone
maybe people here got siblings right
they know that they weren't treated the
same as one other sibling but as a
parent you've got to treat all your
children the same yeah are you going to
give one child one apple and give the
next one half apple or you know or even
though you're my favorite child i'm
gonna give you like all one apple no no
yeah you'll get one apple but i'm just
saying i'm just saying the treatment
like everyone knows that depending on
where you felt in the sibling line
obviously
even with have you guys ever seen sister
wives yeah okay even that the first one
is always going to be the main one
you're always going to have that one
like the first one
no i think you're just saying this to be
nice and that's why when i said that i
would do it it is circumstantial because
it would be how like it would be
something that would be built i don't
think i would just like
start my relationship like oh i want to
be in a polygamous relationship i would
be open to it like depending on because
obviously if you're saying oh i'm going
to cheat even anyway
i'm going to cheat
you know
pause pause pause like you're you're
saying you wouldn't want to be with one
girl so if i'm knowing
then that's me adjusting but i have to
know that like you have to let me
know i agree with that and so i'll give
you that sorry and me saying that i
would be fine in a polygamous
relationship
i i would want to like i would
because i'm agreeing to this i know that
you're going to take care of me so like
i there's going to be nothing that i'm
lacking of like you know you're doing
you're hitting all the spots for me like
you're doing everything that you need to
do as my man are you fine in this
relationship as long as your wife number
one
or can you be like if you if you want
number two or three i think i could be
because the thing is in this sense like
how you're saying you're you're supposed
to
provide and do everything for the woman
and
i
this goes along i was teasing you like
oh because you can't be 300
because you can't be 300
but the thing is if you're if you're
giving what you need to give
because say say um
say if you look at uni
you can pass with a 40. you're not
giving 100 you didn't make a first but
you still pass like you did what you
needed to do to get through so that's
what i'm saying like if you give what
you need to give in that relationship
it'll work yeah but the least i give is
the better for you
in the sense of this girls don't
necessarily like a man that's on them on
them like you know like
it works better when you're on me like
i'm i'm i've got too much i've got not
enough time for you in the sense of in
the perspective of how you see me like
oh he's always busy he's always doing
his thing like every moment that he
spends with me is special because he
just stops like it's
it's better than it's better for that
until the gardener comes around to do
the grass
yeah yeah